Now I'm going to read a short story by
Kurt Vonnegut,
Jr called Harrison Bergeron.
The era was 20,
81 and everyone was finally equal.
They weren't only equal before God and
the law.
They were equal every which way.
Nobody was smarter than anybody else.
Nobody was better looking than anybody
else.
Nobody was stronger or quicker than
anybody else.
All this equality was due to the 211,
212 and 213th amendments to the
constitution and to the unceasing
vigilance of agents of the United
States,
handicapper general.
Some things about living still weren't
quite right though.
April,
for instance,
still drove people crazy by not being
springtime and it wasn't that clammy
month that the h,
g men took George and Hazel Burger on
his 14 year old son,
Harrison,
the way it was tragical right,
but George and Hazel couldn't think
about it very hard.
Hazel had a perfectly average
intelligence,
which meant she couldn't think about
anything except in short bursts and
George,
while his intelligence was way above
normal,
had little mental handicap radio in his
ear.
He was required by law to wear it.
At all times it was doing to a
government transmitter.
Every 20 seconds or so,
the transmitter would send out some
sharp noise to keep people like George
from taking unfair advantage of their
brains.
George and Hazel,
we're watching television.
There were tears on Hazel's cheeks,
but she'd forgotten for the moment.
What they were about on the television
screen were ballerinas.
A buzzer sounded George's head,
his thoughts flattened panic like
bandits from a burglar alarm.
That was a real pretty dance.
That dance.
They just did said Hazel.
Huh?
Set George.
That dance.
It was nice at Hazel.
Yup.
Said George.
He tried to think a little bit about the
ballerinas.
They weren't really very good.
No better than anyone else would have
been anyway.
They were burdened with sash weights and
bags of bird shot and their faces were
masked so that no one is seeing a free
and graceful gesture or a pretty face
would feel like something the cat
dragged in.
George was toying with the vague notion
that maybe dancers shouldn't be
handicapped,
but he didn't get very far with it
before.
Another noise in his ear radio scattered
his thoughts.
George winced,
so two out of the eight ballerinas Hazel
Song wince having no mental handicap
herself.
She had to ask George what the latest
sound had been.
Sounded like someone hitting a milk
bottle with a ball.
Peen Hammer said,
George,
I think it would be real interesting
hearing all the different sounds said,
Hazel,
a little envious.
All the things they think up or said,
George only if I was handicapper
general,
you know what I would do,
said Hazel Hazel.
As a matter of fact,
boris strong re resemblance to the
handicapper general.
A woman named Diana Moon glamours.
If I was Diana Moon,
clappers said,
Hazel,
I'd have chimes on Sunday.
Just chimes kind of in honor of
religion.
I could think if it was just chimed,
said George.
Well,
maybe make them real loud.
Said Hazel,
I think I'd make a good handicapper
general good as anybody else at George
who knows better than I do.
What normal list said.
Hazel right?
Said George.
He began to think glimmering ugly about
us.
Abnormal son who is now in jail about
Harrison,
but at 21 gun salute in his head
stopped.
That boy said Hazel Dow was a Doozy,
wasn't it?
It was such a doozy to George who was
white and trembling and tears stood on
the rims of his red eyes.
Two of the eight ballerinas had
collapsed to the studio floor and we're
holding their temples.
All of a sudden you look so tired,
said Hazel,
why don't you stretch out on the sofa so
as you can rescue your head,
rest your handicap bag on the pillows.
Honeybunch,
she was referring to the 47 pounds of
birdshot in a canvas bag,
which was padlocked around George's
nick.
Go out and risk the bag for a little
while.
She said,
I don't care if you're not equal to me.
For Awhile,
George weighed the bag with his hands.
I don't mind it.
He said,
I don't notice it anymore.
It's,
it's just a part of me.
You've been so tired lately.
Kind of wore out,
said Hazel,
if there was just some way we could make
a little hole in the bottom of the bag
and just take out a few of them.
Lead balls just a few two years in
prison in $2,000.
Fine for every ball I take out.
Said George,
I don't call out a bargain.
I if you could just take a few out.
When you came home from work,
said Hazel.
I mean you don't compete with anyone
around here.
You just sit around.
If I tried to get away with it,
said George,
then other people get away with it and
pretty soon we'd be right back to the
dark ages again with everybody competing
against everybody else.
You wouldn't like that,
would you?
I'd hate it.
Said Hazel.
There you are.
The minute people start cheating on
laws,
what do you think happens to society?
If Hazel hadn't been able to come up
with an answer to this question?
George couldn't have supplied one.
A siren was going off in his head
wrecking it all fall apart.
Said Hazel.
What would said George blankly?
Society said Hazel uncertainly was.
Wasn't that what you just said?
Who knows?
George,
the TV program was suddenly interrupted
for a news bulletin.
It wasn't clear at first as to what the
bulletin was about since the announcer,
like all announcers had a serious speech
impediment for about half a minute and
in a state of high excitement,
you announced you're tried to say,
ladies and gentlemen,
he finally gave up and handed the bullet
into a ballerina to read.
That's all right.
Hazel said,
if the announcer he tried,
that's the big thing.
He tried to do the best he could with
what God gave him.
He should get a nice rates for trying so
hard.
Ladies and gentlemen said the Ballerina
reading the bulletin,
she must have been extraordinarily
beautiful because the mask she wore was
hideous and it was easy to see that she
was the strongest and most graceful of
all.
The dancers for her handicap bags were
as big as those worn by 200 pound men
and she had to apologize at once for her
voice,
which was a very unfair voice for a
woman to use.
It was a warm,
luminous,
timeless melody.
Excuse me.
She said,
and she began to get making her voice
absolutely uncompetitive.
Harrison Bergeron age 14.
She said,
Nick Rockwell squawk has just escaped
from jail where he was held on suspicion
of plotting to overthrow the government.
He is a genius and an athlete is under
handicapped and shouldn't be regarded as
extremely dangerous.
A police photograph of Harrison Bergeron
was flashed on the screen upside down,
then sideways,
upside down again.
Then right side up the pictures showed
the full length of Harrison against the
background calibrated in feet and
inches.
He was exactly seven feet tall.
The rest of Harrison's appearance was
Halloween and hardware.
Nobody had ever been born.
Nobody had ever borne heavier handicaps.
He'd outgrown hindrances faster than the
h,
g men could think them up.
Instead of a little ear radio for a
mental handicap,
he wore a tremendous pair of earphones
and spectacles with thick wavy lenses.
These spectacles were intended to make
them not only half blind,
but to give them waning headaches.
Besides scrap metal was hung all over
him.
Ordinarily,
there was a certain symmetry,
a military uniqueness to the handicaps
issued two strong people,
but Harrison looked like a walking junk
yard.
In the race of life.
He carried 300 pounds at the offset.
His good looks,
the h,
g men required that he wear it all
times.
A red rubber ball for a nose keep his
eyebrows shaved off and cover his even
white teeth with black caps at
snaggletooth random.
If you see this boy said the Ballerina,
do not.
I repeat.
Do not try to reason with them.
There was the shriek of adore being torn
from its hinges,
screams and barking.
Cries of consternation came from the
television,
set the photograph of Harrison Bergeron
on the screen,
jumped again and again as though dancing
to the tune of an earthquake.
George Bergeron correctly identified the
earthquake and well he might've for many
was the time his own home had danced to
the same crashing tune my God sent
George.
That must be Harrison.
The realization was blasted from his
mind instantly by the sound of an
automobile collision in his head.
When George could open his eyes again.
The photograph of Harrison was gone.
The living breathing.
Harrison filled the screen.
Clanking clownish and huge Harrison
stood in the center of the studio.
The knob of the uprooted studio door was
still in his hand.
Ballerinas,
technicians,
musicians and announcers cowered on
their knees before him expecting to die.
I am the emperor cried.
Harrison,
do you.
Here I am the emperor.
Everybody must do what I say at once.
He stamped his foot and the studio
shook.
Even as I stand here,
he bellowed crippled,
hobbled,
and sickened.
I'm a greater ruler than any man who
ever lived.
Now,
watch me become what I can become.
He toured the straps of his handicap
harness like wet tissue paper,
tore straps guaranteed to support 5,000
pounds.
His scrap iron handicaps crashed to the
floor.
Harrison thrust his thumbs under the bar
of the padlock that securities head
harness.
The bar snapped like celery.
Harrison smashed his headphones and
spectacles against the wall.
He flung away as rubber ball,
nose revealing a man that could avoid
thor,
the god of thunder.
I shall now select my empress.
He said,
looking down in the calorie people let
the first woman who dares rise to her
feet claim her mate enter thrown.
I'm all at past,
and then a ballerina arose,
swaying like a willow.
Harrison plucked a mental handicap from
her ear,
snapped off her physical handicaps with
marvelous delicacy.
Last of all,
he removed her mask.
She was blindingly beautiful.
Now said Harrison,
shall we show the people the meaning of
the word dance music he commanded the
musicians,
scrambled back into their chairs and
Harrison,
strip them of their handicaps too.
Play your best.
He told them,
and I'll make you barons and dukes and
earls.
The music began.
It was normal at first,
chilly,
cheap,
silly and false,
but Harrison snatched two musicians from
their chairs,
waved them like batons as he's saying
the music as he wanted it played.
He slammed it back into their chairs.
The music began again and was much
improved.
Harrison and his empress merely listen
to the music for a while listened
gravely.
As those synchronizing their heartbeats
with it,
they shifted their weight to their toes.
Harrison placed his big hands on a
girl's tiny waist,
letting your sense,
the weightlessness that would soon be
hers,
and then an explosion of joy and grace
into the air they sprang.
Not only were the laws of the land
abandoned,
but the law of gravity and the laws of
motion as well.
They reeled whirled,
swiveled,
flounced,
capers,
gambled and spun.
They leaped like deer on the moon.
The studio ceiling was 30 feet high,
but each leap brought the dancers nearer
to it.
It became their obvious intention to
kiss the ceiling.
They kissed it,
and then neutralizing gravity with love
and pure will,
they remain suspended in Arab inches
below the ceiling,
and they kissed each other for a long,
long time.
It was then that Diana Moon clambers,
the handicapper general,
came into the studio with a double
barreled 10 gauge shotgun.
She fired twice and the emperor and the
empress were dead before they hit the
floor.
Diana Moon clampers loaded the gun
again.
She aimed it at the musicians and told
them that they had 10 seconds to get
their handicaps back on.
It was then that the birds are on
television too.
Burned out.
Hazel turned to comment about the
blackout to George,
but George had gone out to the kitchen
for a can of beer.
George came back in with the beer past
while a handicap signal shook him up.
Then he sat down again.
You've been crying.
He said to Hazel.
Yup.
She said,
what about?
He said,
uh,
I forget.
She said something real sound on
television.
What was it?
George said,
it's all kind of mixed up in my mindset.
Hazel,
forget sad things.
Said George.
Hi.
Always do.
Said Hazel.
That's my girl.
Said George,
he winced.
There was the sound of a riveting gun in
his head.
Gee,
I could tell that one was a doozy.
Said Hazel.
You can say that again.
Saint George.
She said,
Hazel,
I could tell that that one was a doozy.
Harrison Bergeron is copyrighted by Kurt
Vonnegut,
Jr.
Nineteen 61.